As a successful
mobile game developer,
one of the most important
things you can continue to do
is update your game with
new content, bug fixes,
and daily offers to keep
your players engaged
and entertained.
But sadly, updating your
game packages incorrectly
can lead to a horrible burden
of updates for your users.
My name is Colt McAnlis,
and there's an easier way
to push out data updates and
keep your applications in sync.
It's called Google Tag Manager.
See, everything in your
game is driven by data.
Everything that makes up your
game-- like levels, animations,
textures, localizations, sounds,
even layouts-- it's all data.
And updating that data
can become a problem.
When you push a new
version of your app,
users are now caught in an
application update cycle.
That is, they can be notified
that there's a newer version
but can decide to ignore it.
As such, it's a common situation
to have multiple versions
of your game out in
the wild, each one
at different states of updates.
In order to keep all your
users on the same page
and keep them from having
to constantly download
new versions of the game,
you need a better way
to distribute updates
to your users.
And this is where Google
Tag Manager comes in.
Tag Manager is a
cloud-based service
to deliver various
types of text-based data
to devices around the world.
It prides itself on removing
the curse of the upgrade cycle
and keeping all of
your users' devices
in sync with the latest data.
It does this by relying
on a key principle.
Different data in
your game should
be updated at
different frequencies.
See, there's a huge separation
between fast-changing and
slow-changing data in your app.
Changing strings
or translations may
happen about once a
week, while small tweaks
to play balance, A/B testing,
or offers may happen daily,
while art or binaries may
only change about once every
two months or so.
So how does Tag
Manager actually help?
In a typical world, when you
want to change your data,
you do so locally,
sign your package,
re-upload it to the
Google Play Store.
And after some processing,
your existing users
will be notified that
an update is available
and they can download the
whole application update.
But with Tag Manager, you can
bypass most of this chaos.
Since your data has
been separated out
from your code
and binary assets,
you push only the
updated data to the cloud
using Google Tag
Manager console.
The next time the
user starts your app,
it'll check if there's
new data available
and sync only the new
information to the device.
And rather than just sending
out the same updated information
to everyone, Tag
Manager allows you
to define a specific
set of rules
to help segment your
user base and send them
different content.
See, users' devices will
submit some sort of device info
to Tag Manager when
they check for updates.
This is then tested
against the set
of rules dictating what types
of updates they should receive,
which then returns the properly
updated data to the right user.
These rules for data allow you
to target specific segments
of your user base and
give them the data that
doesn't influence
everybody else.
The best part is that all
of this logic for syncing
and keeping clients
up to date is
handled under the hood for you.
Working with Tag Manager
is as simple as interfacing
with a few sets of APIs
to fetch your data.
And check this out.
You can further extend the
rules model in Tag Manager
to create automated A/B
testing for your app.
Simply create an experiment
in the Tag Manager console
which comprises of two things.
Firstly, you need a rule
set, which basically
states what variables
to change and what
sets of users to test it on.
For example, you might want to
update the text on your offer
screens for users
who tend to buy
in-game power-ups
differently than those
who buy vanity items.
You'll also need to specify
a desired action, which
is the result of some
user action on the device,
like clicking a button,
accepting a quest,
buying an item,
or killing an NPC.
Once the experiment
is set up, Tag Manager
will do all the heavy lifting
to roll out variable updates
to subsets of your
users on your behalf.
You don't even need
to think about it.
And as users submit
actions back to Tag Manager
for your experiment, it's all
collected and reported back
to the console using the
power of Google Analytics.
So with Tag Manager, you get
the best of your efforts-- a way
to distribute a high
frequency changing data
without users having to download
the whole package again.
You also get a set
of rules, which
you can use to send specific
updates to specific segments
of your user base, and you
get powerful experiments,
which you can create
dynamic scalable A/B testing
frameworks to improve your
game with dynamic feedback
over time, which is
a lot of usefulness
in a little bit of code.
To get started with
Google Tag Manager,
head on over to the
Tag Manager home page
and sign up for an account.
This will give you
access to the console,
doc sets, as well
as the library files
to include in your
client-side packages.
Building a scalable game
for millions of users
is a monumental
task to undertake,
but with Google Tag Manager,
you can ignore all that
and focus on the real
problems-- zombies.
Thanks for watching.